welcome to cbs this morning we begin
with president biden's visit to brussels
today
to meet with our nato allies he says the
u.s is back in the business of leading
the world
the president spent the last few days in
cornwall england at the g7 summit
securing international cooperation on
covet and china among other issues
he's also been drawing a stark contrast
with the america first stance of his
predecessor
ed o'keefe is in brussels ed what's the
president hoping to accomplish there
well good morning anthony from brussels
the president is hoping to build on what
he called a series of productive
meetings at the g7 over the weekend in
england as he tries to restore
relationships with nato allies after
four years of afraid relationship with
the last administration
mr biden is no stranger to these world
gatherings but for the first time he's
getting top billing
at a series of high stakes meetings and
summits here in europe
america is back at the table president
biden is continuing his first
international trip as commander in chief
with plans to reaffirm america's
commitment
to nato we believe that nato is vital to
our ability to
maintain american security
for the next next the remainder of the
century
on the ambitious agenda today the
security implications of climate change
cyber attacks and disinformation
terrorism
nuclear deterrence nato's role in the
resource-rich and rapidly melting arctic
ocean
the rise of china and russia's
aggressive actions
especially against ukraine on russia the
president's already talking tough
days before he's set to come face to
face with vladimir putin
in geneva switzerland there's no
guarantee you can change a person's
behavior in a behaviorist country
autocrats have enormous power they don't
have to answer to a public
mr biden agrees with putin who says the
u.s russia relationship
is at its lowest point in years i think
he's right
it's a low point and it depends on how
he responds to acting
consistent with international norms
which in many cases he has not
but the president believes the u.s can
work with russia on key issues including
climate change
and ending violence in syria they have
also
bitten off some real problems they're
going to have trouble chewing on
on sunday before leaving the u.k
president biden became the 13th american
head of state to meet with queen
elizabeth
ii it reminded me of my mother in terms
of
the look of her and you know just the
generosity the courtesy call capped
three days of meetings with g-7 leaders
that included approving new plans to
counter the rise of china
and overhaul international tax laws but
leaders didn't set a firm date on ending
the use of
coal one of the biggest contributors to
global warming
and progress on those issues can't be
fully achieved anyway
until the world gets control of the
pandemic
here in brussels today the president's
also meeting with turkey's leader
erdogan about that country's continued
military involvement in afghanistan and
the violence in syria
tony that is certainly another
high-stakes meeting to keep an eye on
today
it is indeed edo key for us in brussels
ed thank you very much